it's great to welcome to the program
today margot finn who teaches in the
applied liberal arts initiative at the
university of michigan and wrote a book
titled discriminating taste how class
anxiety created the food revolution
margot so great to have you on today
thanks for having me so this is super
interesting to me of for a number of
different reasons including that because
of my background I sort of have lived in
a number of different food cultures and
have have read a lot about conspicuous
consumption and the different ways in
which sometimes people choose to display
either sort of cultural knowledge or or
in sometimes some cases monetary status
so let's go back a little bit at what
point did there start to be sort of
multiple food cultures that started to
correlate with some class elements of
society as well that's a great question
I think that there's probably been a
relationship between how people eat and
their social class as long as there's
been social classes and perhaps even
before there were you know the kinds of
groupings that we would recognize as
social classes today food has always
been associated with power and hierarchy
and how you express your identity so
it's it's not like there was a moment
where all of a sudden people started
performing class through food food has
always been a way that we express who we
are in relation to other people so it's
always been available as that vocabulary
to express class what are some of the
examples about a belief about food that
results from or connects to economic
anxieties or concerns let me see if I
can think of a contemporary example so
what one that I sometimes use is the
affinity for kale which we tend to
recognize right now is something that's
sort of a symbol of the alternative food
movement it's seen as something that's
healthy and virtuous maybe not that
delicious although you've got people who
will you know who will advertise that
they've got a great massage kale salad
or something like that but the way
people are talking about kale it's got
this weird symbolic power to like kale
means something about you and people are
using that I think sometimes to express
that they have this interest in health
interest in sustainability but it's also
going along with us
and food culture that we do associate
with the upper-class right now so to
advertise the way people do on t-shirts
and shopping bags that you know like
kale to the victors there's one that you
see in Michigan is a way of trying to
express that you're part of this elite
food community or that you have these
concerns that are true of the elite food
community that's interesting because you
so there's this idea so kale is a good
example in the sense that you said that
very clearly kale is associated with
certain economics but it's not totally
clear that kale tastes that good and
there's sort of a question mark around
whether it actually does or doesn't
taste good
is there a divide in terms of whether
the sort of more whatever we would call
them more elevated foods economically
are actually better tasting foods and is
it really just a matter of preference
can we even assess that in any kind of
empirical way I I don't know if there's
a new such thing as like an empirically
good tasting food because we we eat food
but we eat food with stories and the
stories that we tell food tell us
whether or not so we could say that yes
there's maybe an innate preference for
sweetness but you'll also get emphasize
I think more true among the upper-class
a real sense that too sweet is not good
it's infantile or it's or like generally
disliked I don't like super sweet things
right because I've been either taught
that I'm not supposed to or I've
acquired different tastes so what I
think happens is that people get
motivated to like different things
they're motivated to try different
things so I'm not saying that like rich
people are pretending to like kale I
think that they may have had more of an
incentive to develop an affinity for it
to try that massage kale salad and find
out that if you eat it enough times or
if you think of it in a certain way yeah
you might really like it I don't think
they're faking that they like kale I
think that there are reasons that they
like kale that are connected to what it
might say about them and not have
anything to do with its health or what
it actually tastes like I mean I wonder
how much of this has to do with the
preferences that are sort of instilled
at a young age in this sense which is
that we know that the the foods that are
cheapest per calorie are often foods
that contain subsidized ingredients corn
being one example so when you look at
the products that have
for example a lot of high fructose corn
syrup and our cheaper per calorie or
some of these other products it seems as
though if for economic reasons at a
young age those are the foods that one
becomes accustomed to that that probably
has a big role to play later on in life
in terms of preferences I think that
there is a sense that people have an
affinity for kick for you know the foods
that they ate as kids that you get used
to certain tastes but I'd be wary of
oversimplifying that narrative I think
that that's actually a story that we
like to tell about poor people right
they can only they eat this junky food
because they can only afford this junky
food and they're making an economically
rational choice to get the cheap
calories and then that's all they know
how to like and eat and I don't buy any
part of that narrative texting everybody
eats junk food people of all social
classes particularly as kids and that
doesn't mean that people eat that way
their whole lives many people's eating
preferences transform so the the rich
people who are eating kale right now as
adults mostly I don't think grew up
eating kale as children I don't think
that they were given their kale you know
in the 1950s 1970s whenever they grew up
that that just wasn't a part of the food
culture in the same way and certainly
wasn't there wasn't a sense in the
seventies that we need to feed kids kale
to do this taste education that people
will talk about now and yet many of
those people grew into adults who really
love their massage kale salads they do
change their tastes over time right yeah
I think you're definitely right I guess
the question would be whether the tastes
might change for more people were they
not may be constrained by economic
factors when maybe some people's
preferences start changing but I guess
it's it could be some part of all of
these anecdotally or to some degree I
guess I'm not sure I'm thinking out loud
here yeah I think the one thing that's
interesting is because food does so many
different things and tastes us to emit
so many different things that we can we
can say these things that have a certain
truth to them right like people like
familiar flavors oh that's true but
people also like novel flavors right so
people seek foods that are comforting
that they grow up with but they also
seek foods that are adventurous and new
to explore new things so I think you
know we can so when we tell these
stories about why do people like the
things they like one thing that we have
to be careful about is falling
there's very easy narratives but they
can also conflicted just like the idea
that we're all eating better we know so
much more so much more information and
on the other hand oh we're eating junk
and it's crap and our food systems been
terrible does you know those both can't
be true it can't be everything is
getting better we're learning more and
also somehow we're forgetting all of our
ancestral wisdom like those don't both
get to be true well it could be
economically stratified right where you
you see a larger and larger divide
between I mean that's in a sense what
you're talking about when you talk about
the appeal of kale to certain people but
not everybody we could simultaneously
have more information about what's good
to eat and growing numbers of people who
are suffering from obesity and
food-related illness because of
inequality some the assumptions people
make about obesity and how it correlates
with social class it's really
complicated so it's true that among
white women rich white women are much
thinner than poor white women but it's
not as true if you look across race
divides and if you look across gender
divide so among Latino men and black men
the wealthier you are the more likely
you are to be obese interesting and it's
and I forget what the relationship is
with black women I believe that richard
black women are thinner but it's maybe
not statistically significant in any
case so it's not the case that just poor
people or fatter there's some real
differences in how those demographics
are changing and it's not even clear
that people are getting so so much
fatter people have gotten fatter
somewhat in the last unit forty to sixty
years depending on how you're counting
but it's not a huge amount it's not
everybody and it's certainly not just
the poor so you know is it that poor
people are eating junk food and getting
fatter and fatter while rich people are
learning more about food and eating
better and better I don't actually think
either of those things are true and when
we look at things like who eats fast
food it's everybody right across the
income spectrum about everybody eats
about one fast food meal a week it's not
like it's the poor people eating fast
food and the rich people aren't where do
specialty diets fit into this and that
could be specialty diets that I mean I
guess we could categorize them a few
different ways you would have some that
whether they are for health reasons or
for other reasons or a mix kind of
depends but we're talking about
everything from
veganism and vegetarianism gluten-free
which is increasingly popular paleo
there are now some prominent people who
have tried the carnivore diet and
different versions of that fruitarianism
ketogenic diets are those my instinct is
and I'm glad that you're pushing back
against sometimes what seems obvious is
not true my instinct is that there is a
certain degree of privilege associated
with some of those choices where does
that fit into the conversation that
we're having well I do think I think
you're right I think that we at least
there's a cultural sense that these are
the kinds of diets that it takes a kind
of privilege to pursue many of them
involve eating foods that are more
expensive especially if you're talking
about paleo low-carb those are the meat
centric diets it's really hard to do
that cheaply so I think there you do
have to have a certain kind of economic
privilege and also maybe access to
knowledge and more than that I think
even access to the kinds of cultural
rewards so I think some people are
really rewarded for trying new diets and
for aspiring to different things whether
it's health or ethics through their diet
and I think for some people the
incentives and the rewards aren't there
right in some communities to eat vegan
is not going to be rewarded it's not
going to be seen as an admirable choice
it's going to be seen as weird or
antisocial or fussy or picky or bizarre
those things aren't going to be so
you're you're not going to be as likely
to try it if that's the way your
community is going to see it and if
that's the way people are going to react
to you as if people are going to react
with like oh you look great and oh
that's so good for you and oh I couldn't
do that you know like just a different
kind of reaction that people get for
those diets so you you mentioned the
fast food element that that there are
wealthy people middle class people poor
people and and generally speaking the
amount of fast food consumption seems to
be similar how do we explain the
positioning of fast food across the
economic spectrum when Donald Trump was
running for president there was a lot
made of he's having buckets of KFC on
his private plane
he loves his taco bowls and he loves
Hispanics I mean that was a whole other
Fiasco that we could talk about but in
any case the taco regardless of his
feeling about Hispanic people the Trump
Tower taco Bowl was really great where
does
fast-food element that in culturally and
economically I mean I think fast food
does have a different meaning for people
depending on where you're located so it
is true that when poorer people eat out
they are more likely to eat at a
fast-food restaurant because
full-service restaurants are more
expensive but they're not necessarily
going to be eating fast food a whole lot
because fast food isn't that cheap right
the average fast food meal cost about $7
and the average meal cooked it eaten at
home cost between two to four dollars so
it is true that poor and working-class
people eat more meals cooked at home
because they can't afford to eat up even
at fast-food restaurants if they do eat
out they're more likely to eat at a fast
food restaurant than a full-service
restaurant right so richer people have
this option of fast food restaurants and
more elaborate restaurants and when they
choose fast food they're not choosing
you know to go eat a meal out they're
choosing the quick convenient thing
that's often true for poor people too
whereas they have the option of the
nicer restaurant meal as well yeah I
mean it was so when I lived in New York
City
I would sometimes walk by Olive Garden
and it was packed and Olive Garden in
New York City is not universally less
expensive than an actual local Italian
restaurant and I remember at the time
really giving some thought to that and
imagining well maybe there's tourists
who know Olive Garden and they don't
know what's a reliable local Italian
place like there has to be more than
just the economics of it when the price
seems to be relatively similar I wonder
what you would make of that well yeah
there's all kinds of things going on
right who thinks that the hole in the
wall or family-owned or authentic
Italian restaurant is definitely
superior right what class of people is
going to think that that even if in fact
sometimes a lower price at a family
restaurant is going to signal to them
authenticity and perhaps the promise of
better tasting food then then Olive
Garden which is a chain and because it's
mass-produced is sort of inherently
barred from having authentic credibility
so there's just I do think that it's the
story and what's going to appeal to two
different people in the story is
familiarity and maybe I mean a lot of
people love Olive Garden right like the
free there the endless breadsticks and
the salad and the soup it's good food
and you know what you're gonna get and
it's the same thing every time there are
some people who that's gonna appeal to
and I do think that there are class
dynamics to that to whether or not you
value familiarity and reliability and
something that's going to be pleasing to
you and your whole family or whether or
not you value having an adventure trying
something new doing something that might
be authentic and exotic that might
expose you to some other kinds of people
that you then can return to your safe
life but you had you know some
adventurous experience these are in some
ways maybe their personality things
right it's not that there aren't people
who are adventurous eaters even if they
have extremely you know limited means
but it does mean that there's just
different rewards that are going to
motivate different people and it's not
clear to me that it's the rich people
doing all the good things and the poor
people doing terrible things really
different stories our diets within the
same culture right now obviously if we
can compare the average Japanese diet to
the average Kenyan diet they will be
very very different but within countries
within cultures is the range of diets
way more disparate now than it was in
times past or has or is that not
necessarily the case that's a that's a
good question it's a big question I
think it depends on what you're talking
about right like there's been military
conquest and globalization global
encounters that have changed how people
eat for a long time and whether there's
homogeneity within countries or empires
it depends on the moment depends on how
many people are being grouped together
how big the country is I think you know
with the with the more rapid movement of
people in foods and ideas you may get
more diversity within some places but on
the other hand you'll you know hear
people talking about the
industrialization of food and maybe that
sort of flattened out the way some food
cultures look or made things more
homogeneous that's there so there's kind
of so many moving parts it's a hard
question to answer it's a good question
we've been speaking with Margo Finn who
teaches in the applied liberal arts
initiative at the University of Michigan
the book is called discriminating taste
how class anxiety created the food
revolution
Margo really appreciate your time and
super interesting stuff thanks so much
for having me